foreign
[Music]
hope everybody is ready here we go let's
roll the cameras we are 1571 so these
games
are getting pretty juicy
our emphasis on the opening is
increasing
and presumably we're gonna start getting
a lot of main lines
so this is where you know the brunt of
my opening instruction will come in
we haven't gotten too many Sicilians uh
with the black so hopefully we get
something more mainstream Marianne gilea
from Romania mainstream okay 1e3 but
still move like E3 is not that uncommon
and it's worth knowing
how to play against it it's worth
knowing how to play against it so my
recommendation against 1d4
is going to be the grunfeld and the
great thing about playing the grunfeld
I'm actually going to make a move so
that the game doesn't abort the great
thing about the grunfeld okay scratch
everything that I'm about to say clearly
our opponent is playing some sort of
troll opening
and E3 and D3 in and of itself is not
that bad if white transitions into a
hippo setup so the hippo setup is where
yuffie and keto both of your Bishops and
then put the knights on E2 and D2 but
some players who really troll they go
like C3 and B3 and A3 and it still is
very valuable to know how to punish
those setups because a lot of players
they either get scared or they start
stumbling on their own moves so in this
game I'm gonna offer a sustainable
way to punish uh whatever our opponent
ends up playing so since our opponent
has played D3 it no longer makes as much
sense for us to stick with a grundfelder
king's Indian setup right we need to
play in slightly more principled fashion
since our opponent is giving us an
opportunity to grab the center that's
precisely what we are going to do so
let's transition to more principal chess
and play the move E5
and obviously our next move is going to
be D5 and our opponent continues to play
in a rather dubious fashion let's grab
more of the center with D5 I've had my
fair share of Hippo games in previous
speed runs you can kind of look around
to find to find a few of them
and I've tried to be consistent in terms
of the setup that I offer against these
incredibly off-beat openings one element
of the setup that I prefer is to refrain
from putting the other Knight on C6 I
actually really like a setup where we
play the move Pawn to C6 creating a
little very solid Pawn chain and then
the Knight on B8 can maneuver itself to
the king side it kind of Rue Lopez style
via D7 and f8 to G6 and we have all the
time in the world to improve the
position of our pieces because white is
playing so unambitiously that we don't
need to like hurry and rush to complete
our development so let's start with a
move that solidifies our Center and
takes the sting out of the move Knight
F3 what move am I thinking about here
and this move goes really really well it
complements the move C6 well if you're a
London player you should be familiar
with this type of setup where you put
the bishop on D6 or in the London you
put your Bishop on D3 and then you form
the pawn triangle with C3 and here we're
doing much the same thing we're
defending the E5 Pawn with our Bishop
and we're defending the D5 Fawn with our
pawn and then we get a super compact
nicely positioned Center okay so we can
Castle kingside we can play C6 the order
of operations here is very unessential
right it doesn't matter because white is
not challenging our Center
so I think that our best bet well we're
going to start by castling I don't see a
reason not to Castle kingside we're
definitely not going to Castle queenside
in this type of position that is uh way
too adventurous we don't need to
ReDiscover the wheel here
so
we're gonna Castle kingside
and presumably our opponent is going to
play Bishop B2 white is playing some
sort of a hippo setup but in the hippo
you normally aren't advised to play the
move H3 right because if White NOW plays
G3 then White's created an additional
Target on the king Side by playing H3 so
this really is not a Savory setup At All
by white but before we get to the Crux
of the game when we enter the middle
game it's important to temper your
expectations when you're playing against
these types of setups I can't tell you
how many games I've seen between
beginners or Club players where one side
employs a very offbeat setup that you
know is bad and the other side just goes
directly for the throat and ends up
losing the game because that kind of
play backfires it's not like white is
doing anything to lose the game and we
need to refrain from the temptation to
go directly for White's throat we need
to play this very patiently we need to
get all our pieces out and we need to
understand that breaking down these
types of setups takes time and it's
impossible to do it in the opening
okay so white plays G3
now we're going to continue with our
setup
and play the move C6
now if we want to exert some pressure on
the queen side there is a very kind of
typical idea that we can employ at some
point not necessarily immediately we
also could have played that move here
and what I'm talking about is the idea
of advancing the pawn down A4 and poking
and prodding at the queen side now of
course if we bring our Pawn down to A4
white is going to respond by playing B4
but in that case the typical follow-up
is to chip away at White's Queen Side by
pushing the pawn to C5 and again because
the center is closed we have to realize
that moving the same piece twice moving
the same Pawn twice is not something
that you should rule out right because
there's no hurry here okay so how do we
proceed so I think a lot of people would
be tempted to develop this bishop to E6
or to F5 but we're actually going to
leave this bishop on C8 for the time
being
the reason I don't like Bishop F5 is
because you're walking right into G4
kingside expansion or you're walking
into a potential E3 E4 Bishop E6 is a
better move but I don't really see the
reason for us developing it and another
specific thing I don't like about Bishop
E6 is that after Knight F3 Knight B to
D7 white has the rather annoying move
Knight G5 and we certainly don't want to
give our light squared Bishop away why
don't we want to give our light squared
Bishop way because if you think about
the middle game white is very likely to
Castle kingside and one of our typical
plans is going to be to put pressure on
the H3 Pawn
so don't be afraid to leave one of your
pieces on its initial Square how should
we proceed I think we should continue
developing with Knight B to D7 and then
we are going to reposition the Knight to
G6 by playing rookie 8 which is a good
move in and of itself right this move is
not going to hurt we're reinforcing the
E5 Pawn this is called over protection
and now we are going to guide our Knight
over to f8 and then toward G6
okay Queen E2 but that changes a lot I
was obviously expecting white to play
Knight E2 what queen E2 signals to me is
that our opponent is flirting with the
idea of Castle in queenside
and that is a a suicidal plan but it's
not immediately obvious that castle and
queen side is losing here right and if
white does Castle Queen side
we the Checkmate is not going to play
itself we need to position ourselves in
such a way that if White Castle's Queen
side on the next move we are going to be
ready to jump right into the attack and
I've already pointed out the main
attacking method on the queen side which
is especially good if there is a king on
that side of the board what am I talking
about what should we play we're gonna
play a move that basically tells our
opponent don't you dare Castle queenside
don't shoot dare Castle queenside
because I'm gonna be ready to make
mincemeat out of you A5 very good
and if our opponent goes Queen side if
he dares then we play A4 B4 and C5 and
we blast the queen Side open I'll show
that after the game instead our opponent
plays E4 okay
so E4 is a totally reasonable move
and we are going to continue with our
initial plan of course and get this
Knight over to G6 and you might wonder
what the Knight is doing on G6
especially because it seems to be
restricted heavily by The Pawn on G3
but you what you have to remember is
that ultimately we are going to go after
White's King no matter which way the
king castles right so just assembling a
piece on the king side is a good idea in
and of itself the other thing that I
like about the Moon Knight G6 is that
the pawn on E5 is very nicely protected
by a lot of our pieces and if you think
about it White's got quite a few pieces
staring at E5 as well so whatever we do
I think it's quite important for us to
keep the E5 Pawn nicely protected and so
Knight G6 makes sense both from an
attacking perspective and from a more
defensive perspective as well and those
types of moves are always really good
what if white doesn't Castle well we'll
cross that bridge if we get there I
think we're at will Castle I'm expecting
our opponent to play Knight gf3 we will
accelerate our Pace a little bit and I
have a very interesting idea in response
to Knight F3 that we could try
uh we'll wait for our opponent to play
this move
yeah of course we could have also tried
the move 96 but after Knight F3 we can't
get we we're not able to squeeze our
Knight into D4 and what I don't like
about the Knight on E6 is that it blocks
both of both the rook and the light
squared Bishop so that Knight on E6
would really get on the nerves of our
other pieces we want each piece to be
out of the way of the other pieces
okay so some of you may be wondering why
I'm not exchanging the pawn on e4 and I
don't see a reason why we should
exchange exchanging helps white a lot
more than it helps black because it
creates for the D2 Knight a stronghold
on C4 and it opens up the D file and who
stands to benefit from that open D file
well it's definitely white because white
is ready to get a rook to D1 and then
our Queen on d8 is going to end up under
some serious fire we're gonna have to
move our Queen away and then the
knight's gonna jump into C4 so we're
letting light unfurl his pieces and
expand the pawn on D5 is a very
important Cog in the machine because
it's restricting the Knight on D2 and
we're never afraid of white exchanging
on D5 that just yields total control of
the center to us Queen F1 our opponent
not really playing too actively here
and I really think the time has come for
us to start punishing this I think the
time has come for us
to show our opponent that this kind of
play is is not acceptable now how are we
going to do that well a lot of you are
probably contemplating the idea of
pushing the pawn down to H4 and that's a
very legitimate idea I actually was
considering to play H5 but in response
to Knight F3 I think here we have a much
more readily available attacking option
an option that that I've already pointed
at pointed out and I think now is the
perfect time to put this into effect to
carry this out
when I say we want to punish white for
this type of play what do I really mean
what does it mean to punish in the
context of Chess Well normally what that
means is we have to open up the position
unless we open up either the center or
one side of the board we're never going
to be able to actually punish white for
playing passively if the position
remains closed white can do whatever the
hell he wants he can go King E2 for all
we care right so we have to find a way
to open up some Avenues of infiltration
and we have a really good way of doing
that right we've already played A5 so
let's carry out the idea I mentioned
earlier with A4 we are inducing B4 and
if I doesn't play before then we take on
B3 and we open up the a file
why is it good to open up the AFL well
then we can attack A3
but that ship has sailed and now we play
C5 and we blast open the entire position
white has been very naughty
and now white has no choice but in one
way or another to accept the opening of
the position white cannot keep things
completely closed here he plays he takes
D5 I don't think that's a very good move
what is our response to that move have
we blundered upon
now if we blundered upon have we given
up our main Center Pawn no we don't
really care about positional
considerations anymore all we really
care about now is opening up the
position as much as we can and at that
point the position is largely going to
play itself what do we do now well
obviously we take on B4 and we need to
reassess the situation right there have
been a lot of Trades the position has
transformed what's going on well on the
surface we have given up a center Pawn
for a corner Pawn but that those kinds
of General considerations could not
matter less because they're about to
Checkmate our opponent
all right now we need to be calm here
and we need to go for Simplicity over
over something fancy perhaps some of you
are attracted to the move A3 but it
doesn't work calculate C takes B4 a
takes B2 Rook takes rook and notice that
the Knight on D2 is covering the
promotion Square so we do need to move
our Bishop or do we we have a sacrifice
here that we should consider there's the
very interesting move Knight takes D5
straight away
and if white accepts the bishop then we
take back with our Knight and we have a
gazillion threats in that position we're
threatening to take on D3 with another
Fork we're threatening a fork on C2
so
in a Blitz game I would take on D5
without a second thought also what I
want you to see is that if white plays
Bishop takes D5 very importantly after
Queen takes D5 The Rook in the corner is
hanging uh otherwise white would have
simply taken the bishop but this is the
speedrun
and I do want to emphasize Simplicity
and straightforwardness in the speedrun
so
I'm also very tempted to just drop the
bishop back to C5 because the pawn on on
D5 well I guess it can be defended white
can play the move C4 but then we can
bring our Queen out to B6 and we can
attack F2 so I'm really torn I'm kind of
conflicted here to be totally honest let
me actually take a little bit of time to
think about this I'm going to try to
calculate Knight takes D5 and make sure
that it's actually good
so takes
takes Knight takes before
white can play the move Rook to A3 then
we have a fork on C2
it does look very good now let's compare
that to Bishop C5 Bishop C5 C4
maybe we can push the pawn up to A3 ah
what the hell let's do it Knight takes
D5 let's have some fun
let's have a little bit of fun
yeah I just feel like if you look at
White's King white is not even close to
castling
what the the the the the final
consideration here for me is the fact
that white is nowhere near castling and
as long as the white king remains in the
center I just don't believe that white
can hold this position together another
thing to remember okay and we have the
immediate payoff this is obviously a
impulsive panicky move I was going to
say that really players under 2010 to
panic in these types of situations and
they tend to panic very very quickly so
you often don't need to wait very long
for a a terrible move to arrive at the
seat
so what do we do why is King E2 a
terrible move well it's a terrible move
because he's blundering the pawn on D3
with check
and I don't see a reason for us not to
take it
now the game is not over because well
it's over if white drops the king back
to D1
then we give h2l we give a check on C2
obviously and we win the bishop back and
then the game is totally over
if White had gone King E1 we would have
had to demonstrate a little bit more
finesse in order to finish the game off
and I'll show you what I would have done
after the game
it's a little bit anticlimactic but
still let's try to be accurate until the
end of the game this is an instructive
moment this is an instructive moment
because I think the majority of people
would grab the bishop without a second
thought but you have to remember that
when you've got an attack of this
magnitude you really should be looking
for checkmate you you really should not
be prioritizing material unless it's a
queen right if you can win a queen or
you can win a rook that's one thing but
a minor piece probably we should look
for something a little bit more
ambitious so let's see if we can find a
forced mate
I'm actually thinking about something
but it doesn't seem too clean I'm sure
it's winning so I think the low hanging
fruit here is the idea of pinning well
obscuring the queen right so the first
thing that I see when I look at this
position is the fact that the king and
the queen are aligned so that gets me
thinking about the prospect of moving
the bishop onto either F5 or even to D7
or even the move B6
but anywhere on this diagonal with
skewer the king but let's try to find
the most accurate Square because
well I I like to look at Bishop D7
I really like the look of Bishop D7
because white cannot prevent the Bishop
from moving on to onto V5
so I do not see a defense
in response to Bishop D7 of course
Bishop F5 I think is equally good
I think Bishop F5 is equally good
I don't think there is a big difference
yeah we could also have played rook d8
and I point this out almost every single
time we have a position that's this
overwhelming you might be sitting there
thinking well why didn't I play this
move or that move or the other move
chances are that move is also winning
there isn't just one winning option in
these types of positions there's usually
going to be six or seven moves that all
win the game Queen C1 gets rid of the
skewer but Bishop B5 is still totally
devastating because if the king drops
back to E1 there is obviously a fork on
D3 followed by Checkmate and if the king
Goes Forth King E3 Queen D3 is mate and
King F3 is made in two that I will let
you find what is the fastest path to
Checkmate it's a nice little sequence
it's easy
now remember if we can get the king to
E3 then Queen back to D3 is made
so it's very easy you just need to
Shepherd the king to the right Square
you do that with the retreating move
Queen F5
and after King E3 Queen D3 is checkmate
and our opponent played way too fast and
way too sloppily so
it's a slightly anti-climactic game I
apologize for that
but I still think there's instructive
value to be squeezed
resigns yeah King E3 Queen D3 is
checkmate
and we're close to 1600 with that win
thank you Danish Chestnut for the tier
one
yeah so I'm a little bit disappointed at
the opening that we got because if you
are a hippo player the best way to
actually play the hippo is to start by
feeding ketoing the Bishops so if you
see Grand Masters play the hippo and
that does happen normally in Hikaru for
example likes to play the hippo against
computers because the position is very
closed and engines can sometimes
struggle with that kind of thing I think
he played the hippo against mittens for
example so B3 is the best way to reach a
hippo setup and for example after E5
Bishop B2 Knight C6 you play G3
D5 Bishop G2 you start by fion ghettoing
and after Knight F6 you play E3 D3 and
then Knight E2 and Knight D2 and the
hippo's not actually such a bad opening
uh it's it's not easy to show a concrete
advantage against it
but I don't recommend it really for
anybody under a grand master level
because it hits on all the wrong things
you're not practicing you're opening
fundamentals you're just making the same
crappy moves over and over again and
it's just not fun White's essentially
kind of sitting around and waiting for
black to strike hoping the black strikes
prematurely are in the wrong way so I
won't you know analyze the hippo for
Mike's perspective
I don't recommend it at all
so let's go back to the game E3 Knight
f63 so hopefully it makes sense why I
transitioned to the move E5 if our
opponent had played something more
conventional something like B3 or you
know D4 then we would have played a
grunfeld setup because this is
essentially just a 1d4 opening
you might wonder whether E5 is the best
move here E5 is fine but this allows
white to transition into the English
opening with C4 and also the reverse
French is not bad for white I I don't
think E5 is the best move I think D5 is
a very very legit move here as well but
again white can transition into the Kali
system by playing D4 so I think Knight
F6 is probably the best move objectively
so D3 E5 A3 D5 remember that anytime
white plays before in such positions you
almost always respond with a classic
move A5
and this already induces serious
weaknesses on the queen side
if white takes then white is left with a
terrible isolated Corner pawn and if
white plays B5 then we have a couple of
options we can drive the pawn to A4
isolating the B5 Pawn even further or we
can push the pawn up to C6 essentially
using the pawn on B5 to get our pieces
out and again this type of structure
with the isolated Pawn on A3 is terrible
for white
so do not be afraid of the move before
you don't always have to play A5
yourself
H3 Bishop D6 B3
we Castle
white plays G3
and my favorite setup is to push the
pawn up to C6 and the kind of positional
underpinning of this move is very simple
we want the bishop to be biting on
granite when it fiancutters to G2 I like
this move a lot more than Knight C6 I
think I think the setup with Pawn to C6
is really really watertight it's Compact
and it's easy to play
so white response with Bishop B2 and we
get the Knight out 2d7 and again
remember that piece placement is
temporary so you should not rule out a
move like this because it blocks the
bishop this is your piece and you can
choose to move it again so blocking the
bishop is purely temporary it's
Frankfurt airport right the final
destination for the night is going to be
G6
what about C5 instead of C6 a couple of
people are asking so that's an
alternative setup
C5 is an alternative setup which
emphasizes spatial control but that's
actually the reason I don't like it as
much the problem is that after Bishop G2
obviously the pawn on D5 is a little bit
weaker than it would be if our Pawn is
on C6 right and second of all my
recommendation with white is one E4 and
essentially this is like a reverse Kings
Indian setup so this resembles a one D4
opening with colors reversed but I'm
trying to play against offbeat openings
in the spirit of a one E4 player does
that kind of make sense if you think
about it what is the King's Indian well
the king's Indian and the King's Indian
White gets pawns on e4 D4 and C4 but in
the perk in the perk which is like the
equivalent of the king's Indian against
one E4 you don't get that pawn on C4 so
the distinguishing factor between a lot
of D4 openings and a lot of E4 openings
is that the C Pawn remains on C2 in most
E4 openings so it's not all about the
amount of Pawns that you have in the
center it's also about the quality of
your central control
now how is the game likely to unfold if
you play C5 well White's gonna go Bishop
G2 Black Goes Knight T6 and of course
black is better right this is totally
legitimate setup you can put your Bishop
on E6 and your Center is still very well
defended
I'd be laboring the point here by and
large C5 is just an alternate setup
so we decided on C6
Knight bd7 Rook E8 Knight D2 Knight f8
and so far white is doing everything
correctly and here our opponent starts
going completely off the rails Queen E2
is a very strange move but still not
that bad still not that bad as long as
white would have followed It Up by
actually getting this Knight out to F3
the conventional way to play this of
course is 92 this completes the hippo
setup then we would have played Knight
G6 and likely white would have castled
King's side now what are the available
plans here for black well you can play
both on the king's side and on the queen
side you absolutely can still play the
move H5
and if you want to play H5 it might
actually make sense no I think Knight G6
castles in H5 makes a lot of sense and
you can just chill on H5 right you don't
have to rush the move H4 because the
pawn on H5 is perfectly well protected
by the Knight it's unattackable
and if white plays H4 then white creates
a massive hole on G4 that you can stick
a bishop in and let's not even talk
about the effect of the move F3 so how
much is black better in these positions
I would say objectively it's like 0.7.8
according to the computer so it's you're
not winning
number one and number two you have to
squeeze these positions for a very long
time you're not going to win the game in
two moves so for instance I would maybe
play H5 let's say that white does
nothing let's say that white plays a
random move Queen C1 then I would bring
the bishop out to E6 I would also very
seriously consider the prospect of
playing H4 G4 and the engine confirms
this you can actually sack on G4 in a
lot of these positions we had a Speed
Run game that I won in a very similar
way in this position Knight takes G4 is
already very very strong
because if you look at this position you
have two pawns for the piece White's
pieces are tremendously passive H3 is
coming in and at some point you could
push E4 to open up the dark squared
Bishop so Black's attacking potential
here is massive it's already minus three
according to the engine
white plays F3
simply drop the bishop back to D7
and White's position is indefensible
here the Queen's coming out to G5 the
Pawn's moving to H3 everybody in the
chat intuitively should understand why
this position is terrible for white even
without calculating any variations
thank you Baldur for the right can white
go F4 asks Michelangelo F4 you take it
and the Knight on E2 is undefended so
the funny thing is the random move that
I chose
is actually detrimental to White's
position because it leaves the Knight on
E2 unprotected
maybe white should play a move like King
H1 and here I would develop the bishop
to E6 then I would play Queen D7 and
force the king up to H2
where it is x-rayed by the dark squared
Bishop and one thing that could happen
is after Queen D7 King H2 what move is
once again very very strong who can tell
me uh how black should squeeze the most
out of the position
yeah again H4
and after G4 apart from the sacrifice on
G4 which is still very interesting you
can consider the move E4 check and you
can consider the very typical plan of
moving the Knight off of F6 and Blasting
open the king Side by pushing the pawn
up to F5
and to that you might ask well am I not
worried about weakening my own king and
the answer is no because of how passive
white is white does not have the
Firepower to exploit the weakening of
blacks black skin but the vice versa
statement is untrue our pieces are
positioned perfectly to attack White's
King
if you don't want to play on the king
side you can also play on The Queen side
the exact mirror image of the king side
plan is also effective which is what we
did in the game you can play the move A5
and then at some point you can play the
classic idea A4 B4 and C5 what is the
effect of this idea and I wouldn't
necessarily do it here because here you
have allowed white to play D4 here you
have allowed white to play the very
nasty move d4 and as a consequence white
establishes a very strong Knight on the
Square but what I'm talking about is is
in more general terms what are the
available ideas
assuming that this is not possible you
have isolated the A3 pawn and on the
next move you could attack it by
building a battery forcing The Rook back
to A1 and at some point you could bring
your b-pawn up the board and create a
pass Pawn on A4
okay so I'm just trying to give you I'm
trying to brainstorm some ideas to show
you that just because the position is
closed does not mean you just have to
shuffle your pieces for 50 moves there
are specific things that you can do and
most of them involve reopening at one
side of the board
right and the reason this is such a bad
opening for newer players or
intermediate players is that white has
no activity if you're a white hippo
player you have to be able to just
shuffle your pieces essentially add
infinitum and that's not what you want
to do to build skill and and that's why
it boggles my mind at how many players
just decide on a setup like this it's
masochistic
okay so unless there are any questions
we're going to move to the game I could
talk about this in Far More depth but I
don't want to overwhelm you with ideas
we need to
we play A5 right preemptively pushing
our Pawn up and discouraging light from
Castle in Queen side what would have
happened if White Castle's Queen side
well now we definitely play A4 and we
definitely play C5
and perhaps in this position white could
play B5
but here I think we have a very powerful
move how do we prevent white from
linking up his pawns with C4 who can
tell me and this is a move which may
seem anti-positional you're giving up
some squares but you're essentially
isolating the B5 Pawn not C4 come on C4
D takes C4 just blenders upon
we want to play the move d4
right and yes we're opening up the
bishop and yes we're giving up the C4
square but we are taking the sting out
of the move C4 because here we take on
passant and then we victimize the B5
Pawn with Bishop to D7 and once this
Pawn drops whites King is just going to
be in shambles
so that would be one idea but we don't
have to rush right we don't have to rush
with A4 and we can also start by playing
the move Queen E7 in fact we probably
should do this forcing white into making
this incredibly passive move and now A4
looks a whole of a lot better A4 B4 C5
and again the same thing B5 D4
and on the next move we go Bishop D7
takes B5
am I worried about losing the B7 Pawn I
want to lose that pawn to open up the B
file white has nothing going on the king
side this position is losing
okay
now
John aphrath suggests the idea of
playing Queen E7 Queen E7 is a great
move and it also prevents white from
castling because he drops A3 but I
actually wanted to encourage white to
cast like I wanted to play a move that
sort of provokes white into castling
because it's such a big mistake and we
know that A5 is a helpful move
regardless those are the types of moves
you want to play you want to play moves
that you're not going to regret even if
your opponent does not go along with
kind of the main idea of the move if
that makes sense right so a move that I
would not want to play is B5 because B5
is a pretty weakening move and if white
does not Castle Queen side it's kind of
hard to justify this A5 is a far less
positionally committal move if that
makes sense
okay so our opponent responds with E4
which is a good move Knight G6 and here
I think Queen F1 is perhaps the decisive
mistake I think after A4 White's
position is borderline lost
what should white have done well
obviously white should have brought the
Knight out to F3
and in response to that I had a couple
of ideas
I think the most non-committal move is
actually to play Bishop D7
why not Bishop E6 because we want to
maintain the X-ray between the rook and
the Queen
Bishop D7 White Castles okay the engine
proposes to play Slowly with a move like
H6 which I like just making some Luft
and the game goes on again it's the same
we play In The Same Spirit
that we would play If The Knight was on
E2 we squeeze we make improvements we
can play a move like Queen C7
reinforcing the pawn
and largely White's position is
miserable not because black has a
specific idea that makes it miserable
just because white has no active plan
White's pieces are so cramped and so
passive this is like a king's Indian
attack but down like six Tempe another
thing I would consider is to start with
Queen C8 and force the king up and then
go Queen C7 because later on you might
be thankful that there's an x-ray going
on and still the idea of H5 H4 uh is is
is very much feasible for black
okay and I still like the idea of going
A4 and C5 at some point
so one of the key takeaways from this
game is that in these closed Center
positions you have to be really patient
you have to be ready to play five or six
moves that slowly improve your position
but you also have to be on alert for
tactics right you can't fall asleep
because you never know when the blunder
could come
how would I keep improving here well
I've just shown a lot of different ideas
let's say that white literally goes back
to G1
well I would already consider the move
A4
and after B4
uh I would have to calculate the move C5
this is a very committal option the
engine doesn't like it now analyzing
with an engine in such positions can be
quite dangerous because as you guys know
engines are not always very good in
closed Center positions they often
essentially suggest a strategy of
shuffling your pieces back and forth so
sometimes you really have to prod the
engine to look at more concrete lines
for instance the engine does recommend
the move B5 which is interesting
expanding on the queen side let's say
that white continues going back and
forth now the engine proposes the move
Rook a to d8 which is reasonable
okay let's say y continues to go back
and forth
now Queen B7
and okay and A4 so the engine does spot
the idea of going A4 and C5
yeah and now apparently Queen A7
and then C5 is very strong because in
the event of the exchange you've got a
very strong battery against the F2
Square so I think you can kind of see in
what direction I would take this type of
position right you play patiently and
then you find the best opportunity to
reopen the game
okay enough on this position let's have
a look at the game continuation Queen F1
A4 B4 C5 and I explained this pretty
deeply during the game so I won't go
over the logic again I think White's
last chance to stay alive was probably
to play B5
and once again this is a recurring idea
how should black continue in this
position who can tell me
actually the engine proposes C4 just
blasting the center open but if we want
to play this uh in in a human way we
play D4 we close down the center and we
do it in order to pick off this B5 Pawn
92 and the best way to do it is actually
Queen to A5
because the Knight is also pinned
White's position is so miserable here
or you could play C4
DC
and now just Knight takes E4 just smash
through the center
and this position also looks terrible
for white you can give a check on A5 I
mean just look at at this piece of crap
on the queen side this clunker C3 Bishop
E6 Rook C8 is coming we're gonna win
this Pawn now white is losing
so I think the position is beyond repair
already after C5
but our opponent makes it worse e takes
D5 is probably also a mistake
and I'm very curious what the engine
thinks of the move Knight takes D5
the engine likes it yeah Knight takes D5
is the best move
also very good would have just been to
drop the bishop back also very good and
after a C4 we just put the bishop back
on B4 in order to pin the Knight and who
can tell me after Knight gf3 what is the
most straightforward winning move for
black this should be absolutely
automatic your hand should be reaching
for this move the moment white plays
Knight F3 because you know what the
strategy is E4 just blasted open
de494
King D1 A3 play on the flank
Bishop D4 and now the simplest is just
to develop the bishop let's say to F5
do not be afraid to take away from the
previous game to play normal developing
moves in the midst of an attack not
every move needs to be a sacrifice or
needs to threaten Checkmate just bring
your pieces out and then go Queen D7 and
queen A4 check encircle the king and
Checkmate it right so people really
struggle with moves like Bishop C8 to F5
in the midst of an attack but you
haven't sacrificed anything so you're
allowed to play a move that's on the
slower side
Knight C3 check of course is also quite
good black is completely winning
no but you're not pausing and Bishop F5
is an attacking move
but not all attacking moves are created
equal you have different categories of
attacking moves some are sacrifices make
a move to blast open the center but
there are other attacking moves that
just bring a piece into the attacker
into the game
Bishop F5 G4
what happens here I think we ignore
I think we play I'm not using the engine
here
okay at this point I would already start
calculating concretely
and I would consider the move Queen D7
GF let's calculate Queen A4 check and we
find the Checkmate here King C1
and you know I think it's time for
another slow move
okay let's check the engine I'm curious
yeah and I was right the move Knight G6
to F4 is -12.
calling reinforcements you're aiming for
E2 which is a check Manning Square
white is totally busted totally busted
um why there's no moves just just look
at the king and look at White's pieces
for instance Knight takes E4 Rook takes
C4 let's say white plays Bishop E3
squeeze the queen into B3 and we attack
C4
these are pretty simple moves
you just need to get experience in
attacking chess to find them smoothly
in any case this is completely one-sided
so Bishop f8 was a totally viable
alternative the evaluation here is -5
we decided on the sacrifice and it
really is a shame that our opponent just
folded over so quickly after King E2
Queen D3 the game is over I will just
show one more line after King D1 Queen
C2 the game ends immediately
if White had gone King E1 this actually
leads to an instructive moment because I
think most people would get very excited
at the prospect of Knight C2 you're
probably thinking that right now
but you what you cannot do is just say
oh I see an exchange let's take and then
take and take because remember you've
sacrificed the piece so black is better
here of course probably even winning but
this gives up a Lion's Share of your
advantage why would you trade Queens
here that's that defeats the whole
purpose
so what you have to see here is that
Queen takes D3 is actually not a threat
because in that case we take on D3 and
we win an entire Bishop back so can you
propose a move that essentially
encourages white to trade on D3
it's a Zen move
and it's a very powerful move A3 is
great that's one option
what about doing it with a piece
Rook to d8 beautiful Rook E8 to d8 you
deserve some subs
this attacks the Knight
now if White stubbornly defends the
Knight then what you have to see is that
it's not the queen that belongs on D3
it's the Knight so we go Queen C2 and we
squeeze the Knight into D3 with
devastating effect
white basically has to take now we play
Knights HD3 we play Knight takes P2 and
it's totally winning we've got two extra
pawns we've got three extra pawns the
King on E2 is in shambles and this idea
of Bishop D7 to B5 is going to be
further devastating to the white king
okay does that kind of make sense
hope it makes sense so our opponent just
folds over and dies and Bishop D7 is
just a nice final finesse to get the
bishop to B5 with decisive effect
any other questions obviously the
Checkmate here is to go back to F5 and
force the king to move to E3 and then
the queen moves into D3 with mate
okay we've got a couple questions Knight
F4 check instead of Queen takes D3 check
yes that was also winning and I did see
that move we could start with the move
Knight F4 trick I just thought this was
a little bit too advanced for the speed
run
basically the idea is that after G takes
F4 now you play Queen takes D3 check and
what is the purpose of sacrificing on F4
it is to reopen the e-file at your
convenience
but this should make sense to everybody
and the game is over King D1 Queen C2 is
literally checkmate and if white plays
92
then oh the top engine move is sexy
oh this is a sexy and I will give you an
exact parallel for this move
let's take a little detour and let me
tell you a story
let me tell you a story
so rewind the clock back to uh an
Olympiad
that took place in the city of
Gothenburg Sweden
in the year 19
55.
so obviously
uh in that era the USSR team was totally
dominant they basically won every
Olympiad so USSR is playing Argentina
and Argentina actually had a very strong
team they had Miguel neidorf they had a
guy named Oscar Pano who was an opening
specialist Herman pilnick International
master and they had a strong board for
so this was not a walkover for team
uh Soviet Union
so
essentially the USSR had all one E4
players uh ye FM Geller Paul Karis
everybody on that team was essentially
exclusively an E4 player so team
Argentina gets together in pono's hotel
room and they decide to do something
very interesting they all decide to play
the same opening
they decide that they're going to
prepare this opening very extensively
and they're going to show team USSR that
you they are not afraid of a theoretical
struggle that they believe in their
preparation and because Miguel neidorf
was on team Argentina he was the team
captain and he says we're playing what I
like we're playing the night off
so they all agree we're playing the
night off
so they played the night arf and they
knew they looked up Geller's games
the FM Geller was the Elder Statesman of
the Russia team so people were going to
play what Geller plays and Geller was a
bishop G5 player
so
to the Elation of Team Argentina they
play Knight arth on all boards
and Russia responds with Bishop G5 on
all boards going right into Argentina's
preparation and because this was 1955
the theory of the night ORF was still in
its kind of
initial stages and so Argentina came up
with a line that obviously nowadays is
considered extremely well analyzed it's
um not a surprise at all but back then
it was virtually a novelty
and it goes Bishop E7
Queen F3 on two of the boards on two of
the boards obviously H6
Bishop H4
G5
F takes G5
and in this position they had prepared
the line Knight F6 to D7
I don't know if they called it the night
off back then I don't think so so this
is has since then been known as the
Gothenburg variation because of where it
was played but amazingly FM Geller years
ago had analyzed this line
and he had to come up with essentially a
refutation
and the refutation goes as follows does
anybody know how USSR refuted this line
and this is often referred to as the
Argentinian tragedy
Knight takes E6 is correct and the crazy
thing is since then engines have found a
way to revive the line so the best move
according to Modern engines the actual
refutation is Queen F3 to H5
but back then Yeller shocked Pono with
Knight takes C6 F takes C6 Queen H5
checking f8 now Argentina had analyzed
this position
and concluded that they actually that
the peace sacrifice is on sound why did
they conclude that the peace sacrifice
was unsound because here's the thing
what does white want in this position
well obviously white wants to put a rook
on F1 so if you allow white to put a
rook on F1 or to Castle the game is over
because King G7 Queen F7 is Checkmate
right
but here's the thing Argentina was
expecting the move Bishop E2 or the move
Bishop C4
but this is just too slow and black is
able to escape with the move Knight E5
and the point of 95 is that it covers
the F7 Square
and after White Castles black safely
plays King G7
the square on F7 is protected
and all that white can try
is to drop the bishop back to G3
okay what is the purpose of Bishop G3
well white wants to eliminate the Knight
on E5 and deliver Checkmate on F7
but no harm no foul black just plays
Knight C6 and we're fine because the
knights defend each other and the king
is perfectly safe G takes H6 Jack Rook
H6 leads absolutely nowhere
but to the absolute shock of Team
Argentina on both boards
where the argentinians played this line
both Soviet players responded with the
same crazy move
if you've understood and paid attention
to the line I just showed you should be
already able to come up with that move
Bishop F1 to B5
Bishop F1 to B5
and the point of course
is that after King G7 or sorry after a
takes B5 it's mate and we know how
after King G7
uh the move is to Castle
and after 95 Bishop H4 to G3 the point
of the move is revealed the Knight can't
get out to C6 or D7 it can but you're
just gonna capture it and then you're
gonna capture on E5 and Checkmate the
King on F7
and there is very little else that black
can do in this position
here's the reason why if black tries
Rook f8
then white wins with Queen takes H6 and
G6
if black tries Queen G8
then white wins with a beautiful idea
takes takes and now a move that's gonna
knock your socks off
Bishop B5 to E8
threatening Rook F7 forcing the queen to
E8 and now the deflection with G takes
H6 you can't take with a rook because
you get mated on E8 or sorry you lose
your queen
if you step back you lose your queen and
if you step to the side you get
checkmated with Rook F7
so that's the reason you can't play
Queen G8 how else can you try to defend
F7 well there's only a one other move
and that's 95 to G6
but now another beautiful tactic gh6
Rook H6 and who can find the follow-up
who can find the follow-up
and we're following the game Geller
against Pono
or no we're not fine I'll show you what
panel played I'll show you what Pono
played
Rook F7 beautiful and queen takes H6 a
takes B5
check
here forced check
back and we just take everything I mean
just look at Black's position
so in the actual gelerpano game
Oscar Pano uh played the immediate 95
Geller played Bishop G3
and here Pono is already totally lost
because if Black Goes King G7
this is an even worse version of the
line we just analyzed of course black
should go King G7 first but he was so
shell-shocked that he played 95 first
here white can eliminate the Knight
first and castle
and this eliminates the option of Knight
G6 so here white wins on the spot
so oscarpano played uh Bishop takes G5
and lost after castles King E7 and of
course Bishop takes C5 and the game is
over because uh because it is Queen B6
check
was the game King H1 d e and Geller
hunts the king down check
here check and Pono resigned in three
moves he has to give up his Queen in
order to avoid getting checkmated and
the other game ended in very similar
fashion
story that's the Gothenburg tragedy why
did I tell the story hopefully you were
sufficiently entertained but people on
YouTube might be wondering why what made
me think of that story well what made me
think of that story is the engine's top
recommendation in our game
so in my game Let's flip the board again
after uh Knight F4 check which I was
analyzing Queen takes D3 check King E1
he takes up four check 92 the top engine
recommendation is a very similar
mechanism it's Bishop to G4
and the idea is to play this move with
Tempo and force white to spend the tempo
so that you can get the Roka into d8
without allowing white to make an
additional defending move
if Rook D1 Knight C2 is smothered mate
if the Knight moves Knight C2 is still
checkmate
and if white tries to defend then you
just take on C3 with Checkmate to follow
and it's this important idea of
clearance making a move with tempo
and then bringing a rook into the game
of course there's a million other
winning moves and this is not a rare
theme this is pretty common it's just
something to file away into your mental
directory of of ideas
if white tries Bishop C1
then I think the winning line is to give
a check and Slide the queen over to B3
to set up another smothered mate with
Queen D1
Knight F4 was the best move according to
the engine yeah yeah this is -8 Queen
takes D3 is merely minus six so it
wasn't the worst idea in the world to
take on D3 but yes Knight F4 is the most
accurate move for sure
just to finish the thought
after Queen H5 sorry in the Gothenburg
variation now the reason that Knight
takes C6 is no longer considered a
refutation
is because after Bishop B5 there is this
very computer-ish move Bobby Fischer
actually found this move Rook H7 this
move actually allows black to hold and
according to Modern engines it is a draw
it's a miserable position for black
black has to play a thousand engine
moves in a row but somehow black is able
to hold the draw here
so like castles I think it goes King G8
G6 as you can see this is totally
terrifying Rook G7 Rook F7
and then I think black is supposed to go
Bishop takes H4 takes takes I mean some
line like this and apparently you know
black skin survives but but who really
wants to go for this right but if you
want to play this like an engine you're
supposed to play Queen H5 here rather
than Knight takes C6 but anyways back to
the speedrun game not a long game not a
complicated game but hopefully a good
illustration of how to play in these
relatively closed Center positions
patience
uh and deliberate play is very very
important
okay
I think that concludes the speed run
that's probably enough for this game
those of you who are new to my channel I
have a YouTube channel we are slowly
moving toward 400k Subs so every every
sub counts and allows me to keep going
so thank you to everybody who supports
uh in these difficult times
[Music]